fangen wir mit melanie amann an der
leiterin des hauptstadtstudios vom
spiegel frau am an den bundeskanzler hat
man selten so emotional erlebt und
gesehen wie in dieser gestrigen debatte
war der angriff die beste verteidigung
das klang ganz so also man merkt doch
dass olaf scholz ein bisschen dünnhäutig
geworden ist mit der zeit und die
angriffe von friedrich merz ging für ihn
dann anscheinend einen schritt zu weit
also er hat extrem emotional reagiert
auch wenn ich finde dass diese platte
das 16 jahre lang merkel regiert hat
langsam ein bisschen leid also das ist
ja schon so dass er jetzt auch neun
monate selber im amt ist und man auch
erwarten kann dass ein krisen management
gut funktioniert wenn wir hier gleich
diskutieren zieht man das ab frau ammann
was ohnehin hätte kommen sollen nämlich
die kalte progression und sieht man das
ab was man noch gar nicht richtig
finanzieren kann wie wichtig ist dieses
paket tatsächlich also ich finde für die
kleinen einkommen und die bedürftigen
ist schon einiges dabei also das ist
schon also für sozusagen die kleinen
leute ist es wichtig wenn man so will
aber für die kleinen betriebe bisher
noch nicht also die kritikpunkte sind
schon teilweise berechtigt und robert
habe katja lastminute heute noch
hinterher geschoben das auch noch die
kleinen unternehmer unter diesen energie
schutzschirm schlüpfen dürfen aber wie
viel geld er dafür zur verfügung stellt
und wie das genau aussehen soll das ist
ja alles noch sehr vage das wurde sehr
viel nachgebessert nach diesem paket hat
man gemerkt da kam immer noch außer
denen geben wir auch noch was kurzarbeit
machen wir auch noch die kleinen firmen
kriegen jetzt auch noch was ach ja und
das dritte kind bekommt jetzt auch noch
mehr kindergeld also man merkte dass da
immer noch was hinterher geschmissen
wurde was er nahe liegt dass es
vielleicht nicht gereicht hat bisher
werden wir diskutieren verena bentele
ist bei uns vdk präsidentin sie sind
präsidentin des größten sozialverbandes
in deutschland frau bentele keiner ist
so richtig zufrieden außer vielleicht
sie weil auch die rentner rentner
endlich diese 300 euro bekommen genau
also erstmal freue ich mich dass wir
damit erfolgreich war man unsere
forderung wir hatten die letzten wochen
immer wieder darauf verwiesen dass
rentnerinnen rentner von denen auch
viele eben gibt die kleine renten haben
viele die eben auch jetzt wirklich angst
haben vor einer verdreifachung des
gaspreises und dass es für die jetzt
erst mal als erste rettungsaktion die
300 euro energiepreis pauschale geben
wird finde ich gut war eben wie gesagt
eine forderung von uns werden
angekündigt zu klagen gegen die
steuerbescheide im nächsten jahr wenn
sie rentnerin rentner das nicht bekommen
das können wir zeigen lassen finde ich
erstmal gut ist erfolg aber klar ist
natürlich auch jetzt wird vieles
wirklich auch in der umsetzung hängen
weil für viele menschen sind natürlich
300 euro da noch schnell weg und dann
kommt schon darauf an wird eben auch
systematisch was getan das eben wirklich
strom und gas bezahlbar sind weil mir
schon viele mitglieder schreiben die
sagen ich will ja nicht nur einmal 300
euro haben sondern ich will dauerhaft
mein leben von meiner rente die
vielleicht nicht hoch ist von meinem
einkommen wenn jemand eine familie
allein ernährt mit einem nicht so hohem
einkommen dann schreiben mir die leute
im vdk dass sie davon eben auch leben
wollen dass die leute eben nicht sagen
die us gibt sozialleistungen und
transferleistungen das wissen viele
menschen auch noch nicht ob sie in
anspruch haben aber viele wollen es auch
gar nicht sondern wollen lieber von dem
leben was sie eben auch verdienen oder
an rente sich erarbeitet haben und
deswegen wird das für uns auch der
spannende punkt wie sich das zukünftig
entwickelt die strom- und gaspreisen
gestaltet hubertus heil ist bei uns die
arbeit und sozialminister dieses landes
erhalte sie haben diesen bunten strauß
an kritikern nicht nur zur kenntnis
genommen sondern offensichtlich auch
schon gewogen wenn man genauer hinschaut
nochmal hofft man zum einen auf europa
man hofft zum anderen auf die
bundesländer man hofft auf arbeitgeber
die 3000 euro steuerfrei an ihre
arbeitnehmer zahlen ist das dann einfach
einfach hat das geld auszugeben wenn man
es nicht selber ausgeben muss sondern
auf andere haftungen die darum geht es
nicht ich glaube dass wir auf den
zusammenhang hinweisen müssen warum wir
in der lage sind putin setzt gas als
waffe ein um unsere gesellschaft zu
destabilisieren und wir tun alles in
deutschland das geht nur mit vereinten
kräften zwischen staat wirtschaft
gewerkschaften sozialpartnern um in
dieser zeit diese gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten das ist glaube ich der
hintergrund und wir können dann über die
einzelnen maßnahmen im einzelnen reden
aber ich glaube bei allen unterschieden
der kritik nehme ich mal an dass hier am
tisch und demokratische spektrum
einigkeit ist dass es darum geht ich
habe kurz nach dem 24 februar den satz
gesagt das äußere sicherheit
und innerer frieden also sozialer
zusammenhalt zwei seiten derselben
medaille ist wir haben die gräten von
putin gehört der genau das macht wir
haben allerdings die chance in diesem
land wird das richtige tun diese
gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten und nicht
den nützlichen idioten von toten auf den
leim zu gehen die ja auch bei
rechtsradikalen querdenker zwischen
schon wieder unterwegs sind den menschen
gerade nicht gerade geht es darum
informationen die sie am sonntag in die
öffentlichkeit getragen haben allein
erstmal zu verstehen und zu ordnen und
frau am anna ton gesagt dass da jeden
tag ein bisschen was hinterher kommt
stichwort heutiger tagen robert habeck
wir öffnen den störungen rettungsschirm
auch für klein- und mittelständische
betriebe die haben den letzten drei
tagen natürlich sind sturm gelaufen weil
sie in teilen insolvent gehen oder die
produktion einstellen oder beides ist
ihnen das heute er ist eingefallen ist
es herrn habe gestern nacht ist
eingefallen nein ich will versuchen
vielleicht bei den zusammenhang zu
erklären das erste was wir dieses jahr
die ganze zeit gemacht haben und das hat
der bundeskanzler ein bisschen
deutlicher
formuliert ist erstmal dafür zu sorgen
dass die gasversorgung diesem winter
nicht dazu führt dass wir zwischen
wirtschaft und verbrauchern irgendwas
aufteilen müssen das scheint deutschland
zu belegen jetzt haben wir die kosten
problematik es hat soziale folgen die
wir mit dem paket abfedern wir können
einzeln durchgehen ist was im bereich
grundsicherung da ist ein riesen
wohngeldreform dabei da sind leistungen
für rentner studierende und viel dabei
ich habe zwei aufgabe ich bin arbeits
und sozialen und frau an die
entscheidung das ist vielleicht nicht
aufgefallen und das kurzarbeitergeld zu
verlängern es muss nicht im letzten
tagen eingefahren sondern es war teil
auch der einigung müssten aber eine
firma die insolvent geht die der können
sie ja nicht mehr mit kurzarbeitern 1
darf ich das ganz kurz sagen es geht um
wirtschaftshilfen und ich bin froh dass
oder robert habeck deutlich gemacht dass
das kleine und mittlere betriebe oder
anblick sind weil die zwei probleme
haben das eine ist gestiegene kosten
wenn sie energie einsetzen müssen und
das zweite ist wir haben ja damit zu
rechnen dass die inflation auch
nachfrage also konsum kostet das ist
wirtschaftshilfe die dafür notwendig ist
meine aufgabe ist dass das zu flankieren
kurzarbeit das hat in der korona
pandemie millionen von arbeitsplätzen
gesichert deshalb werden wir mittwoch im
kabinett den vereinfachten zugang zur
kurzarbeit über den winter verlängern
wir werden die im bundestag bitten uns
verordnungsermächtigung zu geben wenn
das ganze wirtschaftlich eskaliert
tatsächlich auch noch nach zu stellen
mein ziel ist das bett drei dinge
hinkriegen dass wenn ich kurz sagen
erstens unsere wirtschaft und unsere
arbeitsplätze für die beschäftigten gut
durch dieses schwierige zeit zu bringen
und drittens diese gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten und dafür haben eine
ganze menge an maßnahmen und start
freuen
nur noch mal sagen was robert habeck
heute gesagt hat heute hat er gesagt
dass das energiekosten dämpfungs
programm geöffnet wird es wird jetzt
ausgeweitet auf die kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmer und bis
wir die preise unten haben breiten wir
diesen rettungsschirm aus was glauben
sie wann hat er sich das überlegt das an
die öffentlichkeit zu tragen es ist doch
total entscheidend den unternehmen das
sichere gefühl zu geben und der sichere
wissen zu geben dass es überbrückungs
gelder auch für die unternehmer gibt ja
ich finde das gut und ich finde es
richtig dass dieses signal gesetzt wird
jetzt muss es schnell umgesetzt werden
genauso wie ich die kurzarbeit statt ist
aber wann haben sie das jetzt
entschieden aber wann wurde das jetzt in
der regierung von der koalition darüber
gesprochen worden und der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat das heute
zum richtigen zeitpunkt deutlich gemacht
nämlich sind seiner rede als
wirtschaftsminister ich kann mich
erinnern wir haben ja das weiß der
kollege sparen ja auch sie wollen jetzt
nicht einsparen fragen eigentlich nein
ich will nur auf folgendes verweisen
dürfen wir haben jetzt über ein paar
jahre krise wir haben cola immer noch
ein zwei jahre schlimme wirtschaftskrise
und der kollege sparen weiß auch dass
man im krisen management auch bereit
sein muss pragmatisch zu entscheiden im
zweifelsfall auch nachzusteuern warum
denn nicht am ende zählt das ergebnis
ist nämlich dass das richtige getan wird
um die wirtschaft und die gesellschaft
gut durch dieses schwierige zeit zu
bringen da noch immer klar dass ich
jetzt eine nachsteuerung ist
das ist ja auch okay nur ist er trotzdem
eine interessante information dass es
noch nicht im ursprünglichen paket
vorgesehen war sondern
du hast noch schnell wäre es mit der
aller hast sage ich ja nicht aber in
eine harke ist sein aber ich sage ihnen
trotzdem vor ammann für mich zählt dass
wir das richtige tun ihre aufgabe ist
das zu kritisieren zu bewerten
einzuordnen sie interessieren sich dafür
was bekannt gegeben ich muss mich dafür
interessieren dass wir das richtige tun
in schwieriger zeit und das tun sie
wir sind in dem zweiten tag diese
bundestagsdebatte er friedrich merz hat
noch mal wir haben ihn damit zitiert
gesagt dass er lieber 1000 euro für die
ausgegeben hätten die ist wirklich
notwendig haben und nicht 42 millionen
und für die 300 euro gibt es plötzlich
dieses herz für die bedürftigen in
diesem land und wo fangen die an wo
fangen die millionen menschen an denen
sie auch sie 1000 euro gegeben hätten
anstelle dieser 300
und da will ich ausdrücklich erstmal die
gemeinsamkeit herausstellen wir haben
die situation in deutschland in
deutschland das zwei stunden von hier
krieg ist putin die ukraine überfallen
hat dass das auswirkungen hat auch für
uns und das wir gemeinsam und da sind
wir als opposition auch von der
verantwortung wir mit übernehmen daran
arbeiten wollen dass dieses land in
dieser schweren zeit zusammen bleibt
putin nicht geschafft dieses land zu
spalten und ich bin der letzte der nicht
auch und da hat der kollege heil recht
sagen würde natürlich entwickeln sich
die dinge über die zeit es gibt ein
drittes entlastungspaket man steuert
nach das ist in krisen so jetzt hat man
aber nur 1 festgestellt bin ich bei
ihrer frage dass vor allem die kleineren
und mittleren einkommen und es sind eben
nicht
zum beispiel hartz 4 empfänger die beim
gas bei den heizkosten ja automatisch
die kosten ersetzt bekommen
die orden auch unterstützung von es sind
vor allem auch und das hat friedrich
merz er gesagt die mit 1800 2000 euro
netto die familie ernähren die gerade
mal jetzt 18 euro mehr kindergeld pro
kind in diesem paket finden und sonst
nichts stehen gerade jeden tag sich
sorgen machen wir diesen strom und
gaspreisen wie sie durch den winter
kommen sondern da ist der teil den ich
einfach kritisieren muss wir haben jetzt
den ganzen sommer l und einen ganzen
sommer konzertierte aktion mit
gewerkschaften und arbeitgeber war
anfang juli in dem wirtschafts und
finanzminister nahezu täglich gestritten
haben das könnte in normalen zeiten
unter zusammen sein in einer krise wie
dieser schafft das verunsicherung dann
gibt es letzten sonntag 22 stunden
showdown und dann gibt es ein
entlastungspaket papier in dem nahezu
die hälfte mindestens mal vom
finanzvolumen völlig ungeklärt ist und
überhaupt nicht klar ist wann was kommt
wie hoch ist der strompreis für wen gibt
es welche begrenzung welche planbarkeit
und das macht mir echt sorgen die
menschenkind richtung winter der fängt
bald an die heizperiode fängt am ersten
oktober an und haben nicht den hauch von
sicherheit was bei strom und gas auf sie
zukommt und das gleiche gilt ankündigung
heute robert habeck ist es gut dass es
dieses bekenntnis gibt aber alles offen
keiner weiß welche unternehmen unter
welchen bedingungen durch welches
programm bekommen wenn der nächsten
rettungsschirm nicht akzeptiert ist dass
in krisenzeiten da bin ich der letzte
der schnell gehen muss aber wir haben
einen ganzen sommer vertrödelt mit
täglichen streit und wohne entscheidet
darf ich vielleicht ergänzen neben den
sommer nicht vertrödelt denn erstens gab
es zwei entlastungspaket jetzt wirksam
werden im wert von 30 milliarden euro
mit dem fokus auf normale und unterer
einkommen im mai entschieden in meinem
entschieden jetzt umgesetzt das wissen
sie das weißt du besitzen uns aus der
krise kennen wir zusammenarbeit das
kommt bei menschen an das waren erste
schritte 30 milliarden euro die wirklich
leuten helfen aber eine ganze menge
dabei auch die energie geld pauschaliert
zum beispiel grad ausgezahlt wird dieses
paketes größer das hat man ja vorhin
beschrieben sie können morgen im glaube
ich in der zeit nach lesen wir dass die
wie das mal nachgerechnet hat das ist
vor allen dingen menschen mit geringen
einkommen tatsächlich hilft weil das
eine ganze menge mehr dabei als die
kindergelderhöhung wir haben
beispielsweise nicht nur die jugend des
mindestlohns zum ersten oktober 12 euro
sondern wir haben
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für menschen
unter 2000 euro gesenkt ohne dass sie
sich beim sozialen schutz verschlechtern
wir haben die wohngeldreform das hilft
vielen menschen rentnerin rändern auch
aber beschäftigten mit geringen auf
die haltestelle mal deutlich sagen man
kann so tun man kann so tun als sei
nichts passiert im sommer das stimmt nur
erstens nicht wir haben schnell
gehandelt mit dem ersten zwei
entlastungspaket und dieses hier hat
maßnahmen wie wir wissen dass diese
krise länger dauert von dauerhafte
entlastung von menschen die wohnung
sondern lieber und werterhalt der
entscheidende ist doch planbarkeit press
strom und gas das sind die gasrohre gern
ja so übrigens noch drängender als strom
zum gas problem nichts außer einer
expertenkommission ist link vorschläge
aller art auf dem tisch auch wir haben
welche gemacht andere haben welche
gemacht nichts entschieden und zum strom
wird eine preis bremse keiner weiß zu
welchem preis ab wann unter welchen
bedingungen die kommt vielleicht
irgendwann pünktlich meine sorge ist
dass nur noch da bin ich mal
zusammenhalt das bei den entscheidenden
fragen rom und gas für diejenigen die
sich gerade wirklich sorgen machen wie
sie über den winter kommen sollen so
seien seine reihe auf covers
entscheidung dabei wir haben massiv und
schnelle entscheidung getroffen die
versorgungssicherheit in diesem land das
ein riesen auf das weiß nicht wer mit
lassen und drittens wir werden gas und
strompreise bremsen der reihenfolge
noch mal anschauen ob es vielleicht auch
eine falsche
wahrnehmung deshalb gibt weil wir etwas
entlastungspaket nennen und ich frage
jetzt nach münchen und begrüße ganz
herzlich karen pittel ökonomen vom
ifo-institut mit dem schwerpunkt klima
und energie ob wir mit diesem wort
entlastungspaket einfach auch in die
irre führen weil wir netto ja nicht
entlasten eigentlich müsste ist doch
eigentlich
belastungs änderungspaket heißen
gut es ist man die frage was man als
referenz heranzieht das ist völlig klar
aber ich muss die kritik im prinzip auch
teilen ihr jetzt gekommen ist gerade im
bereich der der gaspreise also wo man
schon den eindruck hat dass das paket in
einer situation entstanden ist wo strom
gerade in aller munde ist und deswegen
strom auch insbesondere
betrachtet wurde ist es völlig
nachvollziehbar dass hier die speziellen
regelungen noch nicht komplett
quantifiziert sind weil das wird ja
morgen auch auf eu ebene entschieden und
das sollte kompatibel sein aber im
bereich erdgas ist es für die haushalte
und für die unternehmen natürlich noch
äußerst unsicher und wenn sie insgesamt
noch mal auf die situation schauen
selbst wenn menschen jetzt für diese
mehrkosten in sachen energie kommen
könnten und können
werden wird es trotzdem eine
kaufzurückhaltung geben wird es trotzdem
diesen nachfrageschock geben von denen
robert habeck heute auch sprach
davon kann man ausgehen also im moment
ist es einfach noch so dass die
energiepreise natürlich steigen die
inflation ist immer noch hoch das heißt
also die menschen halten sich zurück
auch beim konsum und dementsprechend
sind ja auch heute gerade neue
prognosen rausgekommen wie sich das
bruttoinlandsprodukt entwickeln wird und
dass wir so wie es aussieht eben dann
doch auf eine rezession
zu
gehen was jetzt glaube ich auch nicht
wahnsinnig überraschend ist aber
diese zurückhaltung ist auf jeden fall
zu beobachten ist auch logisch wir sind
frei man noch mal bei der frage wie
fatal die situation jetzt in den augen
der bürger ist und natürlich weiß man
dass wir putin und diesen krieg
bekämpfen wollen und müssen aber wie
lange wird man es noch ertragen im
angesicht einer pleite im angesicht von
insolvenzen in angesicht von
zahlungsunfähigkeit ich habe schon die
befürchtung dass die zustimmung der
leute zur unterstützung dieses der
ukraine der dieses angriffen volkes
schwindet in den nächsten monaten das
sie dass sie bröckelt einfach wenn die
leute ihre eigenen sorgen diese für sich
selber wirklich existenzielle folgen
dieses krieges am eigenen leib spüren
und weil eben dieses paket das liegt
manchmal auch in den zwängen der natur
der sache aber das eben viele schritte
dieses pakets erst später kommen erst in
ein paar monaten kommen und weil das ist
ihnen schon erfolg zu werfen weil die
kommunikation darüber auch so ra tisch
ist und unklar ist wächst natürlich
diese sorge nur noch weiter also dass
zum beispiel der strommarkt so dass man
versucht dort grundsätzlich anzugehen
dass man das auf europäischer ebene
gemeinsam anpackt und dass das nicht
über nacht geht herr spahn ich finde da
kann man schon sagen das ist ein
vernünftiger schritt und man hätte es
auch schon aber man hätte sie
können andere länder haben schon
maßnahmen ergriffen und wir hoffen da
jetzt auf die europäer als er habe ich
noch sagte wir haben gar kein strom
problem und also das ist schon das dass
das stimmt aber immerhin wird jetzt
wirklich versucht da am system auch
etwas zu ändern und vereint was zu
ändern im vergleich zu vorher toller
weise frau pickel haben wie sie auch zur
verfügung um nochmal zu verstehen als
bürger warum wir eigentlich in
allererster linie einen gas mangel haben
und jetzt aber unbedingt am strompreis
etwas verändern wollen eben weiter
diskutieren können sie uns das kurz
erklären
dass der gas mangel der wirkt sich
natürlich direkt auf den strompreis auch
aus weil der strompreis quasi dadurch
gesetzt wird wie das teuerste kraftwerk
was am markt
diese genau das haben wir letzte woche
schon verstanden und erklärt aber müsste
man sich nicht zeitgleich genauso um das
gas kümmern wie wir uns jetzt um
das design des europäischen strommarktes
kümmern wie es immer so schön heißt
absolut also das ist aus meiner sicht
auch die absolute schwäche dieses pakets
dann wenn man sich anschaut wie viel im
prinzip die haushalte zusätzlich zu
tragen haben an stromkosten die sie
zusätzlich zu tragen haben an gaskosten
wenn sich im prinzip die preise erst mal
tatsächlich in ihren rechnungen sichtbar
machen das ist ja noch nicht bei jedem
der fall wie viele werden es erst mitte
nächsten jahres tatsächlich auch sehen
dann wird man eben merken das gas nach
wie vor doch einen höheren kostenanteil
ausmacht als die strompreise jeweils
wenn man es absolut sich momentan
anschaut und darüber jetzt gar nichts zu
sagen verunsichert natürlich wer auf
möglicherweise über 1000 euro mehr an
stromkosten haben 3000 euro mehr an
gaskosten träge 300 mehreren erklärt das
ziemlich deutlich auch warum sich bürger
zurückhaltend auch in ihrem bericht auf
europas zu lösen das eine ist der
strommarkt design muss man europäisch
lösen das thema beim strompreis für
haushalte planungssicherheit zu geben
muss man nicht konditionieren mit der
europäischen lösung das war eine
bewusste entscheidung weil man dadurch
sofort weil man dadurch das geld dafür
generieren will das ist ja der weg den
man gehen will das könnte man natürlich
auch anders machen zweiter teil wird
noch mal sagen sie nach entlasten
belasten gefragt haben alleine 50
milliarden euro und der finanzminister
dieses jahr mehr ein bei der
mehrwertsteuer wir haben rekord
steuereinnahmen weil die inflation so
hoch ist 10 milliarden nimmt man pro
prozentpunkt inflation etwa mehr ein als
staat das heißt also wenn man das mal 10
12 milliarden allein wing kalter
progression in diesem jahr die in diesem
jahr nicht ausgeglichen wird also das
heißt für alle werden hält das mal genau
in den volumina nimmt er kann man schon
die frage stellen ob das unterm strich
klar für einzelne war ändert sich da was
eine entlastung ist und dieser satz wir
haben keinen strom problem dem wir über
sechs monate gehört haben der ist
ziemlich schlecht gealtert wir haben
seit sechs monaten gesagt bitte auch um
das thema strom kümmern auch daraus aber
eine vielleicht fairerweise und ich
würde gern auch die kollegin aus die
professoren aus münchen vielleicht im
rat fragen erstens ist es ja beim
strompreis durchaus was passiert wir
haben mit dem zweiten entlastungspaket
dauerhaft die eeg-umlage abgeschafft ist
eine entlastung von 25 milliarden euro
immer vor allen dingen unternehmen hilft
das aber auch einigen privathaushalten
zweitens wenn ich richtig informiert bin
haben wir beim strommarkt gesagt ja das
was die letzte woche der sendung
berichtet haben nämlich dass das höchste
und teuerste gaskraftwerk den preis und
die windfall profits jetzt gerade ganz
exorbitant für kohle auch für
erneuerbare bedeutet auch für atomkraft
lang und es geht darum das für den
menschen was wiedergeben gerade was die
netzentgelte betrifft beim gas haben wir
eine andere situation
wir müssen einen weg finden in diesem
bereich ich glaube auch weltmarktpreise
zu kommen weil wir da auch riesige
spekulationen erleben und darum geht's
und ich möchte dass das gut
vorbereitetes um sitzt wir werden das
tun und es ist aber richtig mit experten
experten das zu machen und nicht
irgendwie im nebel zu stochern dass sich
die reihenfolge als ich will noch mal
sagen wir haben in den letzten monaten
und gas beschafft bei russisches gas
nicht mehr hatten und das ist teurer
geworden wir haben übrigens auch
öffentliches geld reingesteckt und die
versorgungssicherheit dieses land das zu
sichern wir haben die verzierung schiffe
besorgt das ist teurer wir müssen jetzt
gucken wie wir dass sie für die
verbraucher verbraucher auch begrenzen
aber die vorstellung dass man das alles
in einer nacht machen können das ist
glaube ich etwas was man suggerieren
kann wenn man die opposition ist sich
dessen hat herr habeck monate damit
verbracht eine gasanlage zu fabrizieren
die kein mensch mehr versteht und die
auch wieder gerecht ist noch ökonomisch
sinnvoll für die mehrwertsteuersenkung
habe ich ganz noch vergessen auf die
richtig und trotzdem ist ja aber eine
berechtigte frage ob wir diese gasanlage
eigentlich noch brauchen frau bentele
ist dran wäre es die berechtigte frage
genau wie die gasanlage brauchen für die
menschen ist die berechtigte frage was
eigentlich kommt weil für viele ist zum
beispiel der wohngeldanspruch
januar zu spät weil jetzt angst haben
dass sie die hohen rechnungen nicht mehr
bezahlen können krebsforschung gesagt
viele menschen wollen überhaupt kein
wohngeld beantragen schon jetzt wissen
wir dass in der stadt wie berlin oder
auch münchen wohngeldanträge ewig liegen
dass die menschen lange warten müssen
weil die verwaltung gar nicht mehr
hinterherkommt und deswegen ist wirklich
meinen augen das allerwichtigste den
menschen jetzt relativ schnell wirklich
ein angebot zu machen oder kritische
hilfe ja ich finde immer auf das angebot
wirklich sinnvoll ein strom- und
gaspreis deckel zu haben für den
grundbedarf wir da eben auch wissen dass
während der umverteilung wirklich eine
gerechte sache menschen die sehr viel
mehr geld haben geben auch deutlich mehr
geld für energie aus ist klar die wir
brauchen auch viel mehr energie
proportional und deswegen wäre eben der
grundbedarf denen den menschen zu
sichern gibt es verschiedene vorschläge
der serie lösungen also für mich fest
eine gute lösung auch der dgb sagt ja
und auch ersparen sein 1000 und ich
finde das auch wirklich eine sinnvolle
lösung wie man das umsetzen glaube man
muss es auch da einfach und pragmatisch
machen dass es pro anschluss umgesetzt
wird wenn man dann mit der anfängt wie
viele menschen wohnen hier in sein hier
gemeldet wird dass alles extrem
kompliziert stimmt warum wir hier sind
preis macht man ja fairerweise sagen ist
das genau der plan der regierung richtig
vielleicht können wir einmal ganz
genutzt und es ist großartig dass wir
ihn bei uns haben jemanden der sich in
diesem dschungel all dieser vorschläge
halben vorschläge und ganzen vorschläge
perfekt auskennt dazuholen hermann josef
tenhagen von finanz tipp die menschen
fühlen sich
hertragen natürlich hilflos in
anbetracht der situation vor der wir
stehen
sie sind verbraucherberater sie sind vor
allen dingen auch journalist und haben
sich dadurch gearbeitet was glauben sie
erstens wird und wie wird diese drei
werden diese 300 euro jetzt ausgezahlt
kommen die einfach so da muss man sich
darum kümmern das ist jetzt erst mal die
ersten banale frage wie die erste banale
frage die 300 euro für die arbeitnehmer
die werden ausgezahlt jedenfalls für all
diejenigen die bei einem arbeitgeber
beschäftigt sind diejenigen die
selbstständig sind die müssen sich ans
finanzamt wenden und die würden ihre
steuervorauszahlungen die sie
normalerweise machen einfach um die 300
euro kürzen das sollte funktionieren den
rentnerinnen und rentnern da hat man das
ja jetzt erst beschlossen da wird sicher
auch versucht werden das noch dieses
jahr zu machen dass nämlich ein
kernproblem all dieser beschlüsse dass
ganz viel von dem erst im nächsten jahr
greift und die leute natürlich jetzt die
sorge haben jetzt die rechnungen sehen
und sich jetzt fragen wie sie das machen
können also die rentnerinnen und rentner
sollen auch die 300 euro bekommen wie
man das richtig macht das die dass da
keine leute das zweimal bekommen dass
insbesondere unsere beamtinnen und
beamte die ja zum teil auch in der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung waren
nicht einmal sozusagen aus der beamten
tasche was bekommen und einmal aus der
gesetzlichen rente das muss die
regierung dann noch sehen wichtig ist
dass das vor dem jahresende kommt weil
die leute brauchen das geld jetzt und
dann gibt es ein kernpunkt da wo ich
immer sage dieses wohngeld daher ist ein
beständiges wenn sie so wollen das ist
eine große hilfe aber mit ständiges
tagen ist sie haben wo auch anspruch auf
wohngeld sich auf ihren perso wenn sie
wenig genug verdienen und eine wohnung
haben die geld kostet den antrag zu
stellen machen aber mehr als die hälfte
der leute die in anspruch haben heute
schon nicht und die regierung hat nicht
die hälfte macht es nicht und alle die
es machen würden oder gemacht hätten die
würden ja pro nase 415 euro zu 2 540
euro als vierköpfige firmen wie 740 euro
heizungsunterstützung eben dafür muss
man den antrag aber gestellt haben und
dann muss natürlich die kommune auch in
der lage gewesen sein dass abzuwickeln
also da muss man hohe priorität darauf
legen weil das ist geld was in diesem
jahr noch ankommen würde bei diesen
haushalten und dann kann man also wie
überzeugt man die menschen davon sich
das zutrauen und über diese grenze der
bürokratie oder ist es vielleicht auch
eine schamgrenze zu springen also
eigentlich muss man man muss es
einfacher machen und man muss sie
einfach an der hand nehmen also da
eigentlich muss es ja ein finanzamt weiß
ja welche leute wenig verdienen die
können doch einfach einen schönen
musterbrief rausschicken und sagt
übrigens wir haben darauf geguckt wir
sehen sie kriegen womöglich wohngeld
machen sie das der berliner senat ist am
besten tatsächlich weil wenn sie da
einen wohngeldantrag da können sie mal
rechnen angucken der ist nicht in
sozialversicherungsfachangestellten
sondern in der plaine language also
einfacher sprache da kann man zwei
stehen und dann kann man wenn man da
gesehen hat man kriegt welches da muss
man eben sehen dass man tatsächlich
dieses geld auch bei seiner bei seinem
bei seiner kommune denn bekommt das ist
ja das ist ganz zentral dass die leute
das machen und dann hängt dann noch was
dran und da noch was drin nämlich bei
dem kinderzuschlag also das ist ja auch
geld was familien bekommen die wohngeld
bekommen die kein arzt mehr bekommen
aber die wenig geld haben der hängt
meistens auch am wohngeld dran das sind
zum teil antragsformulare die sogar
zusammen verschickt werden und auch da
geht es bis zu 250 euro im monat pro
kind wohngeld im letzten mal was
gemessen wolltest 180 euro im monat pro
haushalt da gibt es ein richtig großes
und die könnten diesen herbst noch
mobilisiert werden für die familien in
das dringend brauchen da das schreiben
wir darüber befinden sind das ist der
kern und sie haben noch herausgefunden
dass das übrigens auch für eigentümer
geht die waf geld haben das heißt da
lastenausgleich und das kann man auch
als eigenbau mal machen ins ins bild
aber es ist der gleiche
prozess und das gilt natürlich
insbesondere für ältere leute die auf
dem land dann ein haus haben also
ostdeutschland noch vielleicht noch mehr
nicht viel geld haben und sich auf diese
art und weise ebene finanzierung
bekommen können die ihnen hilft das mit
der immobilie über die runden zu drehen
letzte frage entschuldigung verbände wer
ist gleichsam letzte frage in diesem
strompreis dschungel also wenn es der
regierung jetzt gelingen sollte dazu
kommen wir gleich noch mal wie das geht
wenn es der regierung so gelingen sollte
die strompreise zu senken
wie kommt ein stadtwerk damit klar was
heißt dass dann automatisch für die
verträge muss ich mich darum kümmern
kümmert sich ein stadtwerk darum was
denken sie wie das laufen wird das
einfachste ist das österreichische
modell im augenblick die haben einfach
gesagt es gibt pro haushalt 80 prozent
von dem was die durchschnittlich
gebraucht haben letzten jahren die haben
durchschnittlich 3700 kilowattstunden
gebraucht macht dann 2009 100
kilowattstunden und die macht man total
preiswert und das geld muss dann der
stadtwerk sich tatsächlich aus der
zentralen kasse holen vom vom staat oder
wenn die das schaffen die konzerne zur
kasse zu bitten dann eben von den
konzernen dass das muss dem stadtwerk
aber erstmal egal sein da muss es
einfach eine zentrale kasse für geben
das ist ein einfaches modell ist aber
natürlich also ist für großstädter super
weil es sind alle single haushalten die
brauchen keine 3000
kilowattstunden ist aber auch im land
nicht so populär sage ersparen kommt ja
aus einem ländlichen wahlkreis da
brauchen die familien mehr als die 3000
kilowattstunden pro bentele ja das
problem lässt sich wirklich mit dieser
wohngeld idee im prinzip gut ist das
kennen wir auch aus anderen systemen zum
beispiel grundsicherung alter wissen wir
dass unsere beratung beantragen ganz
viele menschen den anspruch haben auf
grundsicherung im alter beantrage es
nicht weil sie nicht wissen dass in
anspruch haben weil sie es bestimmt
finden weil sie sich stigmatisiert
fühlen weil informationen fehlen so
haben wir das wohngeld und wir haben in
deutschland eine wirklich krass
steigende zahl von haushalten die
überhaupt kein erspartes haben laut diw
geht man vielleicht sogar von 40 prozent
der menschen in deutschland aus die
keine also seine ersparnisse haben und
deswegen eben auch nicht jetzt im herbst
mal schnell reagieren können theoretisch
werden auch dass menschen wenn die eben
wirklich auch entsprechend wenig
verdienen was wir erst mal annehmen
können die dann laut antrag stellen
müssten wie wird das soll man das
bearbeiten also das stelle ich mir
wirklich noch als super schwierig vor
und finde hier die umsetzung im
entlastungspaket eben das strom- und
gaspreis dekkers jetzt wirklich spannend
weil das eben dieses thematische lösung
wäre die die menschen davor bewahren
würde und auch die verwaltung jetzt
tausende von wohngeld anträgen dass ich
glaube dass das eine tun und da dürfen
das andere nicht lassen das ist genau
der punkt wenn ich das mal offen sagen
dass mein eindruck ist wir haben
wichtige politische diskussionen hier
aber der beitrag von herrn ten hagen war
für die zuschauer einen zuschauer
wirklich mal was praktisches leben die
sich jetzt sorgen machen und wir haben
eins gelernt bei ihm es gibt dinge
werden automatisch ausgezahlt wie die
energie pauschale die jetzt kommt es
gibt dinge für bedürftige menschen die
zum beispiel mit dem regelsatz kommen
aber es gibt auch antrags leistung und
das ist herausfordernd was wir jetzt
noch gemeinsam tun müssen ist nicht
darüber zu räsonieren dass menschen sich
schämen und wohngeld zu beantragen dann
darüber aufzuklären dass es ihr rechtes
und wie es geht und wir reden an verena
das macht ihr als als vdk das machen ja
ich bin der festen überzeugung das ist
in krisenzeiten so das hat eher sparen
mit gesundheitsämtern erlebt wir haben
im kommunalen bereich in ämtern probleme
in deutschland wir müssen das jetzt
hinkriegen und wir müssen das tun was du
gesagt hast nämlich gleichzeitig an
diesen bremsen arbeiten und sie umsetzen
aber ich will jetzt nicht dass wir die
leute verunsichern sondern es gibt
hilfen und darüber aufklären noch mal
wirklich so wichtig auch hier genau und
trotzdem ist jetzt die frage was mit
dieser strompreis bremse schrägstrich
vielleicht gaspreis brennen sie
geschieht da versuchen sie einen
mechanismus zu finden geld einzusammeln
um dann den menschen erst geld
auszuzahlen
hört es sich so an sagt er gleich
sekunde
die regierung hat beschlossen
der strompreis deckel kommt wie viel
strom zu welchen discountpreis jeder
haushalt kriegt völlig offen denn das
ganze wird finanziert aus über gewinnen
pardon zufalls gewinnen der
energieunternehmen ab wann gewinne
zufalls gewinne sind völlig offen ergo
völlig unklar wie viel man vom
stromerzeuger auf strom kunden umlegen
kann und erst mal soll brüssel schauen
ob sich nicht eine europäische lösung
findet das könnte noch lange hin und
hergehen ausgang offen
wir müssen wieder verstehen verständnis
frage erst will es jetzt also die
europäische union versuchen eine
gemeinsame lösung zu finden wie man
einen über gewinn zufalls gewinn
abschöpfen kann ganz banale frage
glauben sie dass das in wochen in
monaten gelingt
wenn man kann es nur hoffen weil
momentan gehen die eu-staaten dazu über
alle eigenständige lösungen zu suchen
die dann in der regel wieder
rückwirkungen haben auch auf den
stromhandel zwischen den staaten dann
wieder also zwischen frankreich und
spanien konnte man sehr gut beobachten
spanien subventioniert das gas macht die
strompreise billiger was für frankreich
super ist dann exportieren das nach
frankreich subventioniert der spanische
staat französischen strom und da sieht
man wie viel kaskaden effekte da
entstehen also sofern da eine beim
strommarkt design eine europäische
lösung zu finden ist extrem wichtig aber
schwer man hört auch inzwischen schon
extrem schwer also man hört ja auch aus
brüssel schon heute dass es
wahrscheinlich zum beispiel ausnahmen
geben wird wie so viel gas aber auch für
steinkohle dann wahrscheinlich auch
wasserkraft pumpspeicher also das heißt
wie um diese lösung wird weiß der himmel
herr spahn sagt jetzt zum zweiten mal
und das konnte man schon lesen es gibt
eine schnelle lösung sie sagen wir
können nicht auf brüssel warten es gibt
für alle lösungen die genau das thema
eigentlich zu gewinnen adressiert es
gibt das eeg konto das ist also das für
die eeg-umlage erneuerbare energien
wollen ja gefördert über viele viele
jahre da wurde was raus gezahlt
sozusagen von allen stromkunden wurde
geld genommen und das wurde gezahlt an
wind photovoltaik mit der festen sätzen
und das verrückte in anführungszeichen
ist ja gerade weil die strompreise so
hoch sind füllt die sich gerade da wird
nicht raus ausgezahlt da sammelt sich
gerade geld an und das sind eigentlich
klassisch zufalls gewinne das geht zum
beispiel um windkrafträder die schon ein
bisschen älter sind viele
photovoltaikanlagen
die haben einen festen zinssatz den
kriegen die und alles was am strommarkt
gerade gewinn ist läuft auf dieses konto
oder liegen 18 milliarden euro die man
auch absehbar nicht mehr brauchen wird
weil die eeg umlage
deswegen kann man mit diesen acht wollen
ja mal was schnell ist und ich meinen ja
nicht wider erwarten bis frühling ist
diese 18 milliarden könnte machen jetzt
halt zügig nutzen um etwa die
netzentgelte zu senken das sind die für
die übertragungsnetze was ist kunden
zahlen müssen 15 milliarden nächstes
jahr schon dieses jahr könnte man sofort
entscheiden nutzen die stromsteuer
senken macht auch sofort einen
unterschied 6 milliarden könnte man
diese 18 milliarden für nutzen man
könnte sie auch nutzen und der
strompreis bremse zu machen da liegen 18
milliarden einfach werden nicht benutzt
haben sie da schon mal angeguckt in
diesen topf erhält ja aber wir machen
alles richtig ist und richtig ist mit
meiner erstmals also ist es ja eben
beschrieben worden dass der versuch in
schneller zeit mit buslinie
verständigung zu kommen der beste weg
ist und frau von der leyen hier mitglied
der cdu ist herrn spahn hat angekündigt
das ist schlecht schnell hinbekommen
will wir haben gesagt wir versuchen das
jetzt in windeseile wenn das nicht
gelingt das ist der bessere weg über das
mag design zu gehen aufgrund auch der
rückwirkung mir vorhin beschrieben wurde
beispiel spanien beispiel frankreich
dann sollen wir genau den mechanismus
eeg nutzen falls das nicht geht werden
wir national handelt und das relativ
schnell an dieser stelle das ist ganz
klar dass es auch am sonntag in der
koalition vereinbart insofern also
richtig einleuchtend ist es ja nicht
warum nicht trotzdem kurzfristig jetzt
für diesen winter dieses instrument
gezogen wird und ich selber geschrieben
hat ich würde es wird entweder man
zwischen gleis zug schnell gehen oder
wir werden den weg genau so umsetzen wie
es eben beschrieben
ich bin nicht immer ganz ich kann ihnen
ich kann in einem fachbereich rauf und
runter
bewunderer jens spanier konnte letztes
jahr gesundheit rauf und runter jetzt
können energie auf ich habe auch meist
gelang seinen warmen vor der großen
umarmung er nicht ich will nur ich will
nur sagen ich gehöre zu den leuten die
in talkshows versuchen die dinge so zu
präzise zu binden wie ich sie begriffen
und kann ich weiß natürlich als mitglied
des kabinetts was wir da vereinbart
haben aber wer kann ihnen nur sagen dass
wir in diesem bereich strompreis bremse
so rasch ist irgend geht in dieser
koalition zu ergebnissen kommen werden
das ist wird in diesem winter versuchen
aber nochmal das prinzip ist erstmal ich
sammele milliarden ein an diesem
europäischen
strommarkt um zufalls gewinne
abzuschöpfen so soll man es ja verstehen
und das dann zu nehmen um sie den
bürgern zurückzuzahlen das ist geplant
dass irgendjemand muss ja mal diese
größe benennen über wolf ihr geld reden
gehen übrigens noch einmal benennen hat
ja vor jemand diesen strompreis bezahlt
also es ist er eigentlich eine
umverteilung von den einstrom konnten
den hohen preis zahlen die zahlen an
ihren energieversorger von dem wird dann
was abgeschöpft und das wird dann wieder
an andere verteilt das ist sozusagen
eine umlage die irgendwie ne steuer
wirkt von einer gruppe zu einer anderen
wird was umverteilt das sollte man
gelegentlich mal dazu sagen das geld
fällt ja nicht vom himmel
ja aber es ist der tatsache geschuldet
dass die maus anfang ist gemacht was die
bundesregierung äußere der investor
greift gesagt dass opel gestanden habe
in so kurzer zeit fast 18 milliarden
euro liegen wie man sofort
ich fand dich geldfragen dann ich würde
meine frau titel frage ob uns diese 80
milliarden an man kann so ein quatsch es
fehlen und dann ehrlich gesagt nicht
widersprechen dürfen ich wehre mich
jetzt mal dagegen vorerst wird der preis
weil er im nebensatz ja so getan wurde
als hätte sich das marke seien die
bundesregierung ausgedacht nein ich muss
das aber klarstellen im nebensatz von
helfen sparen angesagt der letzten
sendung sagte er um es einmal zu sagen
wir haben die situation in anderen
zeiten möglich so komisch hoch
vernünftig war das ist nämlich
erneuerbare die billigsten sind und in
der berühmten merit order das teuerste
zuschaltbare kraftwerk dass die
versorgungssicherheit bringt den preis
jetzt jetzt nichts passiert aber dass
daraus ergeben sich die über geringe
der zufall zu gewinnen wenn sie so
wollen und es ist vernünftig dass den
bürgerinnen und bürger zurückzugeben das
gefällt mir genau tun gut also dann
haben sie
den eindruck zu erwecken als sei das die
schulter bundesregierung dass es diese
über gewinne gibt das ist das mag design
und wir an den superstar um geht es
darum dass wir lösungen finden nachdem
wir irgendwie jetzt drei monate über
dieses thema wir müssen bei dem strom
ich sage nochmal wir haben drei monate
lang gehört es gibt kein strom problem
habe ich in jeder debatte im deutschen
bundestag von dieser bundesregierung
gehört jetzt reden wir eigentlich über
strom einen solchen wagen eine lösung
finden die leute können ist nicht mehr
zahlen geben geladen und milliarden frau
titel sie sind dran mit zwei erklärt er
fragen und mit dem bösen antworten wie
lange können wir warten darauf dass es
entweder eine europäische oder eine
nationale lösung
das ist relativ also ich denke schon
dass morgen bei dem treffen der
energieminister der eu was rauskommt da
bin ich optimistisch das problem in
allen ländern ja ich bin da optimistisch
ich habe jetzt eine echte aus dem
hintergrund gehört glaube ich jedenfalls
aber die frage ist eben dann wirklich
der teufel liegt im detail dass man eine
lösung findet heißt noch lange nicht
dass diese lösung auch eine gute sein
wird und was man jetzt auch gerade immer
wieder durcheinander schmeißt ist
tatsächlich die eine seite wie regulär
ich quasi die über gewinne oder die
zufalls gewinne wie schöpfe ich die ab
und auf der anderen seite wie gehe ich
bei einer strompreis bremse vor das sind
zwei unterschiedliche dinge da immer
wieder durcheinander geschmissen werden
und das ist aus meiner sicht auch
problematisch das ist schon richtig der
strommarkt die sein dass man absolut
sind das auf europäischer ebene zu
machen den mindestverbrauch oder diesen
verbrauch den mann zuschuss der wird
wahrscheinlich von land zu land
tatsächlich unterschiedlich hoch
ausfallen
verschiedenen ländern unterschiedlich
viel mit strom betrieben wird also dass
zum beispiel halten bei uns heißt man
nicht mit strom in anderen ländern schon
in anderen ländern macht man das ich
hätte auch sagen können dass es wirklich
neu ist dass eine cdu csu sich für ein
abschöpfen von über gewinnen oder
zufalls gewinnen einsetzt auch das ist
sicherlich irgendwie vor vier monaten
noch unvorstellbar gewesen dass wir mal
in einer solchen situation lernen werden
frage aber noch also könnte ich lasse es
jetzt aber es geht ist etwas anderes die
über gewinnen debatte die geführt worden
ist was am ende ja über alle unternehmen
gehen sollte und keiner wusste wie er
über gewinn definiert und wie
unterscheidet man jetzt diese zufall
hier geht es ja und nein hier geht es um
den strommarkt ich hab's dann das was am
strommarkt passiert das ist was völlig
anderes und
europäischen strommarkt geschieht und
was offensichtlich von produzenten
ökostrom kohlestrom und atomstromer
preiswerter hergestellt wird als von
gaswerken jetzt haben jetzt glauben hier
alle noch mal gesagt was denken sie wie
viel geld zusammenkommen hier ist meine
frage ich würde gern noch mal einen
einen punkt sagen der die aussage wir
haben kein strommarkt problem stand
natürlich auch noch aus seiner zeit wohl
nicht abzusehen war dass in frankreich
vom netz geht dass wir gleich noch so
eine extreme trockenheit periode haben
das eben auch der zug soll dafür sorgt
dass teilweise hinsichtlich zum beispiel
der produktion aus wasserstoff aus
wasser eben strom zu produzieren dass
schiffe nicht mehr fahren können mit
kohle beladung also das darf man auch
nicht vergessen dass es da noch zu
gesetzliche weitere gründe gibt warum
der strompreis momentan tatsächlich auch
durch die decke gehen jetzt müssen wir
nicht sagen wir haben wir schon so viel
gas verströmt das nachkriegs beginnt das
jeder gesehen hat wir hätten auch ein
stromproblem schon im april und mai wir
geben die frage haben aber auch
gleichzeitig die atomkraftwerke
abgeschaltet und dadurch haben wir auch
mehr kohle und mehr gas verströmt also
man darf auch nicht vergessen dass wir
das können ja auch
noch mal die frage was glauben sie wie
viel geld wird zusammenkommen
jetzt kann ich ihnen so einfach nicht
beantworten weil es extrem davon
abhängig sein wird wie hoch tatsächlich
dieser deckel sein wird ab wo man
abschöpft weit ist ja im prinzip eine
hundertprozentige genau im moment ist ja
praktisch 100 prozentige steuer wenn man
so will darüber gedacht also wenn man
einigt sich auf 200 an der börse glaube
ich ihr sind jetzt preise bis 500
aufgerufen für die megawattstunde
was würden sie sagen ländern
unterschiedlich hoch ja also ich kann es
eben nicht genau sagen es sind mehrere
milliarden die man da schon erwarten
kann auch in deutschland denn es ist ja
auch zum beispiel so dass auch im
bereich der erneuerbaren energien wir
zwar einige
eigentümer von solar oder
windkraftanlagen haben die immer noch
mit dem konstanten satz tatsächlich auch
also die einspeisevergütung bekommen da
gehen die gewinne eben nicht an sie
selber aber es gibt auch die neueren
anlagen die eben nach dem anderen modell
gefördert werden und die machen momentan
auch recht hohe gewinne die können das
behalten was sie jetzt an strompreisen
tatsächlich auch bekommen und da fallen
durchaus auch einiges an zufalls
gewinnen ab wo man eben auch tatsächlich
abschätzen kann und die schätzungen
gehen in mehrere milliarden höhe aber es
ist ich kenne auch keine tatsächlich
zuverlässige schätzung das
denn eine politische frage die da lautet
zwischen strompreis und gas bremse wird
die ampel in ihren augen schon
inkludiert sein oder explodiert sein
oder halten die noch durch ich glaube
dass das kein thema ist an dem die ampel
aus einer weise zerbrechen könnte es ist
ja eher so dass eigentlich man gar
nichts hört von den koalitionspartnern
was er habe da so vor sich hin wurstelt
oder man hörte teilweise kritik aber ich
glaube dass die fdp und die grünen die
spd teilweise ganz erleichtert waren
dass herr beck mit dem problem da stand
und die wichtigsten energiepolitischen
projekte offensichtlich nicht in den
griff bekommt also weder dieses
atomenergie thema löst er die
gleisanlage sinnvolle weise noch die
gasanlage und die haltung von ihrem
bundeskanzler scheint ja irgendwie zu
sein ich lass den mal machen wenn es
schief läuft dann
weiß er ist schwarz um lang in dem man
hat ja auch bei der vorstellung des
entlastungspaket gesagt und wie das dann
alles konkret läuft mit dem strompreis
dass das regelt ja dann herr harbecke
also da gibt es schon eine gewisse aber
vor den kadi darf ich mal versuchen an
dieser stelle also ich weiss wollte ich
in dieser regierung bin dass olaf scholz
oberst habe die frage
aber ich bin die frage kommt und ich
schwöre es gasanlage frau titel brauchen
wir diese gasse umlage jetzt eigentlich
noch jetzt schöpfen wir ja super als
gewinne ab brauchen wir um juniper zu
retten jetzt eigentlich und dieses sehe
also ein nachfolge eine nachfolge
konzern brauchen wir diese gas umlage
noch die einen unglaublichen
bürokratischen aufwand macht und schon
gegenfinanziert wird mit einer
mehrwertsteuersenkung macht die in ihren
augen noch sehen
also die gasanlage macht aus meinem
blick keinen sinn mehr seit wir im
prinzip die gegenfinanzierung über die
mehrwertsteuersenkung haben die zufalls
gewinnbesteuerung ist dann noch mal eine
andere
dimension eine andere problematik aber
im prinzip zu sagen wir
legen diese gas umlage um und mehr oder
weniger in der gleichen dimension der
gleichen höhe hängt mir dann die
mehrwertsteuer also das ist mir nicht
wirklich klar was da lula da wie ein
widerspruch verraten weil ich weiß dass
das sie aus klimaschutzgründen sagen es
muss nur russ preis signal sein das ist
nicht mein ansatz mir geht es um
folgendes und das war auch der
hintergrund das weiß ich das auch jetzt
wo es geht er darf ich dir irgendwie mal
jetzt wirklich man kann alles chemisch
im dreck ziehen ich versuche diesen idee
mal zu erläutern so wie ich es
verstanden habe meinen begrenzten
niedersächsischen verstanden es ist der
wichtigste punkt in diesem jahr war
erstmals und das wollte ich vorhin sagen
wo der bundeskanzler der finanz und der
wirtschaftsminister wirklich großartige
arbeit gemacht haben die
versorgungssicherheit dieses landes ja
aber das hat ja aber das hat ja mit
diesem thema zu tun mit der gasanlage in
dieser zeit wo man dann hohe
weltmarktpreise hat und hohe spekulation
und ersatzweise gas aus anderen ländern
besorgen muss muss man aufpassen dass
versorger nicht insolvent oder
pleitegehen schieflage kommen das
völlige begründung villiger als umlage
und wir müssen gucken dass es nicht die
falschen bekommen da sind wir uns einig
an dieser stelle es ist keine gute idee
übrigens da hängen ganze menge dran
versorgern halbzeit wo man die
versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten muss
kaputt gehen sagt sie und deshalb war es
richtig zu sagen damit wir tatsächlich
dass wir umverteilen das für die
mehrwertsteuer den menschen zurückgeben
und die ist gesenkt worden das ist der
zusammenhang also ich finde wir müssen
ein bisschen wenn wir ernsthaft über das
thema reden wollen und wissen wo die
ursache her kommt nämlich dass putin mit
gas krieg macht auch gegen unsere
gesellschaft wissen das ist das
wichtigste war dass in diesem winter
überhaupt keine zuteilung von gas
bekommen das hat wirtschaftliche kosten
das hat folgen für unsere
volkswirtschaft
doch zurück die niemand erhob war ich
also sie wehren sich schnell einigen die
hatten meist ganz kurz fragen hätten
hagen und auch da wäre ich dankbar für
eine klare antwort
brauchen wir diese gas umlage noch
verstehen die menschen was damit
geschieht und welcher stadtkämmerer in
diesem land wird in der lage sein eine
ordentliche rechnung für seine bürger zu
entwerfen
wir hätten die gasanlage von anfang an
nicht gebraucht wenn wir entschieden
hätten wir finanzieren das ganze aus dem
steuersäckel und wollen uns das geld
dann wieder die gasanlage weil die
kompliziertere variante aber die leute
die fragen sich jetzt was anderes das
ist das ist bei der ganzen diskussion
die bekommen jetzt eine stromrechnung da
steht drin ihr alter stromkonzern
schmeißt sie raus dann versuchen sie bei
ihrem stadtwerken zu gehen das stadtwerk
augsburg nimmt zum beispiel von
neukunden also die den letzten vertrag
suchen in der ersatzversorgung einen
euro pro kilowatt stunde einen euro das
ist drei mal so viel wie man vor einem
jahr normalerweise bezahlt hat die
deutschen bahn bietet auch an den
strompreis von 19 cent auf 1 euro 57
heraufzusetzen
für neukunden darunter für kunden also
das ist die truppe da sind die probleme
die die leute haben so was können die
jetzt tun die haben zwei möglichkeiten
die haben erstens die möglichkeit bei so
einem stromvergleich machen wir auch so
ein nachzugucken was gibt's denn da
überhaupt und zweitens haben die
möglichkeit zu ihrem örtlichen stadtwerk
zu gehen und zu gucken ob sie in die
grundversorgung kommen diese
grundversorgungs geschichten sind häufig
preis werden das gilt sowohl also
verbreitet zu allem anderen das gilt
sowohl für strom als auch für gas dafür
müssen diese stadtwerke aber natürlich
überleben und um das mal ein beispiel in
potsdam zu machen die kriegen ihr gas
ist eigentlich von uniqa wenn die
sozusagen das gas nicht kriegen würden
potsdam hat vor allen dingen fernwärme
das heißt die leute haben auch keine
alternative bei der heizung dann hätten
die das gas auf dem weltmarkt kaufen
müssen zu mondpreisen und hätten
möglicherweise die heizungskosten
verzehnfachen müssen das sind so
zusammenhänge die da überall sind die
leute wollen einfach für sich nur wissen
sie haben im oktober die kündigung
gekriegt die wollen jetzt brauchen jetzt
einen neuen vertrag und der neue vertrag
muss berechenbar seien auch wieder in
diesem jahr hilfen die im nächsten jahr
kommen berechnungen die sie in
milliarden haus wirken gibt aber den im
augenblick nicht diese gasanlage kommt
am ersten zehn und das wird ja erst mal
durchgeführt die werden wir jetzt haben
haben sie herr spannendes gefühl ich
frage gleich noch nach atom da ist die
fdp an ihrer seite haben sie das gefühl
dass diese regierung auch sehr
komplizierte lösungen erfindet weil die
fdp mit in der regierung ist da muss
jetzt eben vermieden werden am
strommarkt dass es eine neue steuer wird
es muss vermieden werden dass es um
wirkliche gewinne geht es muss vermieden
werden dass es aus dem staatshaushalt
geht macht die fdp das besonders
komplette das kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
frau nicht darum jetzt ja nicht dabei
wenn da gesprochen wird ich kann ihnen
halt nur sagen das ergebnis ich sehe das
ergebnis und ich sehe jetzt kommt eine
gasquet niemand bezweifelt dass es
richtig ist juniper zu stabilisieren
weil sonst ist wirklich versorgungs
themen gäbe die frage ist ja wie jetzt
für eine gasanlage allen die die zahlen
sollen wir ein paar mehrwertsteuer
wieder
entlastet und die gewinne die
unternehmen die die kriegen sind auch
unternehmen die gewinne machen und um
die zu kriegen soll dann wieder
irgendeine übergewicht das ist das ist
halt deutschland tatsächlich in der
ganzen feinheit von regelungswut und das
schlimmste das ist das eigentliche
problem und achten darauf hingewiesen
alle sind verunsichert
es soll jetzt zum ersten zehn kommen wir
haben heute im deutschen bundestag einen
antrag gestellt das könnte der bundestag
nämlich diese verordnung aufzuheben es
gab keine mehrheit dafür deswegen wird
der stand jetzt zum ersten zehn kommen
es wäre leichter gewesen aus heutiger
sicht nach diesen ganzen verrenkung an
das aus dem bundeshaushalt zu machen
dann hätte man übrigens oder mit
garantien auch sagen können wenn es
juniper wieder besser geht vielleicht in
drei und fünf jahren dann zahlen die das
auch mal wieder zurück damit die gewinne
dann nicht sozialisiert werden wir sind
bei atom und haben jetzt noch ganz
schnell zeit uns mit diesem letzten
thema in der sendung zu befassen da
hilft nur noch beten der große
kommunikator strauchelt nach dem chaos
um die gasanlage präsentiert habeck ein
klein bisschen atomkraft eventuell
politik nach dem motto nichts halbes und
nichts ganzes
die pracht werke in bereitschaft zu
halten aber nicht laufen zu lassen es
eigentlich die schlechteste aller
lösungen
denn man hat die kosten der
bereithaltung aber es wird keine
günstige energie produziert die ja einen
positiven einfluss auf den strompreis
hätte
unterdessen warnt der betreiber von i
sah 22 der drei laufenden anlagen zum
jahreswechsel in die kaltreserve zu
schicken um sie bei bedarf hoch zu
fahren ist technisch nicht machbar und
binnen 48 stunden nach herbergs
minimalkompromiss
fordern koalitionspartner und opposition
den weiterbetrieb der kernkraftwerke bis
mindestens in das jahr 2024 hinein
deswegen sind wir sehr dafür diese
laufzeiten zu verlängern auch
gegebenenfalls neue brennstäbe zu
bestellen damit mehr menge eben in den
markt kommt die preise müssen runter ich
sage ihnen herr bundeskanzler stoppen
sie diesen irrsinn
das wird jetzt eine schnelle runde in
dieser sendung es ist ein großes thema
oder es ist auch kein grosses thema aus
den augen der spd aber warum hört man
nichts von ihnen was wollen sie
eigentlich was wäre die fcs spd hat das
mal so persönlich ich bin seit man
kindestagen atomkraftgegner für mich
eher eine pragmatische frage und es ist
wichtig dass die beiden süddeutschen
kraftwerke auch der
versorgungssicherheit wegen weil man da
wenig übrigens in bayern
windenergie ausgebaut hat im nächsten
jahr auch noch zu verfügen wie
und sie könnten jetzt auch sagen die fdp
macht wahlkampf und sagt wer die fdp
wählt wählt sichere stromversorgung
glauben sie die fdp noch überzeugen zu
können wir haben vor allen dingen
regionalen in deutschland probleme im
süden und das hat was mit mangelndem
leitungsausbau und mangelnder von
erneuerbaren zu tun sie sagen dass also
der welt herr beck da getan hat ist gut
ich sage die kraftwerke im süden wo sie
gebraucht werden wir uns zur verfügung
stehen und darauf kann sich jeder
verlassen gibt das ist erstens war der
stresstest sagt alle drei kernkraftwerke
im streck betrieb also durchgehend
laufen lassen weil wir das brauchen für
die netzstabilität du bist nicht nur in
deutschland sondern in europa es ist
eine sehr nationale haltung die die
regierung der gerade einen das
kernkraftwerk in niedersachsen zudem
niedersachsen berkersheim das würde
eigentlich auch gebraucht sagt der
stresstest um die stabilität im
nordwesten zu erhalten im netz vorschlag
habeck 20 kraftwerke auf schiffen zu
mieten irgendwo im norden an der see
fest zu machen und in öl kraftwerken den
strom zu produzieren den er in lingen
nicht mehr produzieren wenn ein minister
habe lässt uns ölkraftwerke auf schiffen
co2 ausstoßen zu horrenden summen
wahrscheinlich am weltmarkt mieten nur
damit die kernkraftwerke klimaneutral
das etwa in lingen doch nicht laufen
müssen ist weil seine grünen gerade in
der landtagswahl bei atom auf den
plakaten haben und das finde ich ist
einfach ein zeichen dafür dass hier
ideologie über das gestellt wird was in
der krise in dramatischen
pragmatisch kann sagen was lehrt das
erste und das am meisten übrigens
regelungs kraftwerk in niedersachsen
weiß was das ist das schon wieder am
netz das ist jetzt hole kraftwerken
wiederum in meinem wahlkreis das am
meisten wie heißt der technischen regel
die kraft und ich habe vorhin deutlich
ja gesagt das geht in der not es geht
natürlich sein und das werden wir tun
frau
bentele würden sie sagen in allem
pragmatismus jetzt alles was wir haben
um so viel wie möglich strom in den
markt zu bringen und damit die preise
vielleicht zu singen also ich würde
erstmal sagen dass politik da wirklich
immer langfristige denken muss wir
hatten ja vor vielen jahren schon die
gelegenheit mehr in erneuerbare energien
zu investieren stellt übrigens auch
viele der für die heute ja aber nicht
genug offen sich dort bekämpft viele
firmen jetzt große gewinne machen ihr
zwar jetzt bin ich mal dran viele bitte
danke genau wie viele firmen die jetzt
ja auch große gewinne machen und die
letzten jahre gemacht haben haben die er
an aktionäre ausgeschüttet wie in europa
zu investieren
und jetzt können wir die unangenehme
entscheidungen treffen in bayern der
abstand der windräder ist ein
riesenthema deswegen wurden keine gebaut
oder dazu wenige und atome kann man in
manchen süddeutschen bundesländern auch
nicht lagern den kann man irgendwohin
schicken und die debatte dass viele
menschen unter stress also das ist es
gerade stress ganz vielen stars würden
sie entscheiden ich würde ganz
pragmatisch entscheiden strom und
gaspreis deckel zu haben für die
menschen das wäre für mich die
wichtigste entscheidung und natürlich
muss die versorgungssicherheit
gewährleistet sein und ich bin zum glück
nicht die energie expertin die atomkraft
ja oder nein sagen muss weil mir geht's
leider auch so dass ich
atomkraftgegnerinnen bin und da kann ich
jetzt nicht so schnell von weg und sagen
ach bitte lasst sie doch laufen du hast
ja nichts sich aber nie entscheidend ist
das eine gute variante eine gute lösung
die er habe da gefunden hat diesen
reservebetrieb oder schließen sie sich
frau grimm an und sagen das ist die
schlechteste aller lösungen
da schließe ich mich absolut frau grimm
man darf auch nicht vergessen dass der
stresstest quasi für diese
atomkraftwerks lösung nicht und halten
schlechtmöglichste bedingungen gelaufen
ist das heißt also das war nicht die
schlimmste situation in der wir sein
könnten und man kann sich vorstellen
wenn wir die getestet hätten dann würden
die atomkraftwerke noch mehr an
zusätzlichen nutzen bringen